what's popping Florida men it's me Mt
and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show and my God after what felt like a
million years of waiting Rockstar Games
has finally dropped the first cinematic
teaser trailer for Grand Theft Auto 6 a
trailer that revamped the old familiar
playground of Vice City by introducing
some fresh new faces in an astonishingly
beautiful world of nextg detail we're
going to go ahead and break down all of
those details in this trailer frame by
frame so that we can consume every
criminal crumb that rocks star games has
finally decided to feed us after all
this time so grab your bandanna and get
ready to secure the bag cuz we're about
to get into this thing and right off the
bat the trailer shows us how incredible
this next generation of Grand Theft Auto
is going to be by starting us off with
this beautiful wide shot of a sunrise
over Vice City covering the entire scene
in a pink and blue glow to match the
iconic pink and blue color theme that
has become synonymous with this
fictional region ever since 2002's GTA
Vice City the year that Rockstar opened
our eyes to how committing a series of
small war crimes on the street of an '
80s Miami parody is even better when
you're running from the US military
blasting Phil Collins greatest hits that
pink and blue color scheme was of course
initially chosen for GTA Vice City due
in large part to that game taking a ton
of inspiration from the hit influential
TV show Miami Vice a show that is parody
in this current HD GTA universe as Angel
in the night Vice City pi and I really
think that this pink and blue theme ties
super well into the fact that we are
going to be controlling a female and
male protagonist throughout this story
in the foreground we can see a truck for
Patriot beer which is a fictional beer
brand established during America's
founding in 1776 and is very popular
amongst the most patriotic of rednecks
and rockstars HD Universe especially the
Lost motorcycle gang and it's also a
brand that was retroactively added into
the definitive edition of GTA Vice City
in 2021 and can be seen inside America
love and establishments like the REI
Chopper bar a bar that used to be the
headquarters for big Mitch Baker's
motorcycle gang the Vice City bikers and
because the Patriot beer brand is
primarily marketed to a heavily redneck
audience the company also has strong
connections and sponsorships to the
world of professional racing even owning
a racetrack called The Patriot beer
Motor Speedway and hosting a wild
redneck racing event called The Patriot
500 so definitely expect to see a few
Patriot beers in the hands of the
car-loving thrill billies Mud Club in
GTA 6 we can actually see a six-pack of
patriot beer on the table that a drunk
party guy jumps onto in the trailer but
speaking of biker gangs this trailer of
course confirms that they'll be making a
comeback in GTA 6's modern take on Vice
City as a weasel news broadcast can be
seen capturing a dirt biking gang
recklessly driving past police officers
responding to the scene of a car crash
this particular bike gang appears to
have some connection to the Little Haiti
region of Vice City as well as the shot
in the trailer where they're introduced
contains a Haitian flag on a build
building at the end of the road possibly
alluding to the return of the Haitian
Street gang in GTA 6 there might have
actually been a slight tease to the
growing influence of the Haitians in GTA
5 in particular when radio host Danny
Brown references a new zombie weed from
Vice City hitting the Underground Market
which is apparently some really strong
ass stuff I believe that this is not
only a reference to hades's past
connections to zombies and Voodoo
culture but also hints at the possible
influence of the Haitians gang leader
Auntie pulle who was voiced by the late
yui D Harris aka the famed TV psychic
Miss Cleo who very confusingly performed
her GTA role as a Haitian gang leader
with a Jamaican accent which always
throws me off as a Haitian man if you
remember aunti pulle made a number of
voodoo potions for protagonist Tommy
versetti in order to influence him to
work to destroy her rival gang of Cubans
voodo potions that made Tommy forget
those very missions that he did for her
as soon as he did did them but anyways
the opening shot of the trailer also
features a prison in the backdrop which
seems to be the very same prison that we
soon see GTA 6 protagonist Lucia trapped
in Lucia is of course the first playable
female protagonist in a rockstar game
with her romantic partner Jason likely
being the second playable character of
that game bringing back the character
switching system that was first
introduced in GTA 5 with Franklin Trevor
and Michael we first see Lucia watching
inmates enjoy some wreck time in the
beautiful Vice City weather from her
cell inside possibly implying that Lucia
might have gotten her outdoor privileges
taken away by violating some prison
rules like starting a fight or something
we can also see that Lucia is a very
family oriented person as a picture of
what appears to be her family hangs on
the wall above what looks like her bed
on the bottom though this is a bunk bed
so this could easily be a photo of her
cellmates family the family photo does
feature a man wearing orange in the
middle possibly implying that Lucia
might not be the first person in her
family to have gone to prison before
Stephanie the prison counselor who talks
with Lucia also has a number of her own
family pictures on her desk while also
sporting a name tag that appears to say
Vice Institute of Correction which is
likely the name of the prison that Lucia
is at but I'm not too sure because the
details of that name tag are still quite
blurry but anyways when Stephanie asked
Lucia if she knows why she was
incarcerated Lucia responds with bad
luck I guess which definitely shows that
this Corrections Facility has failed to
show Luc
the error of her ways as she still
simply blames being incarcerated on the
misfortune of having been caught for her
crimes not because that she actually did
something wrong and if I were to guess
exactly what got Lucia locked up in the
first place I feel like it likely has to
do with this liquor store robbery that
we see Lucia and her booth and Jason
kick the doors into at the very end of
this trailer leading to them fleeing the
scene and the crime at high speeds but
eventually still getting caught but that
of course has yet to be seen but the
fact that they're both wearing the same
outfits and bandana masks in the store
robbery and getaway shots it definitely
feels like all of those shots were from
one particular robbery gone bad but
while we're on the subject of that
liquor store robbery let's go ahead and
break it down frame by frame starting
with the last shot of the trailer of
them kicking down the doors of Uncle
Jack's Liquor store with what appears to
be the face of Uncle Jack on the door
also on the doors are several GTA
Universe alcohol Brands like logger
light with logger being GTA's parody of
the Miller brand pendo cesa which looks
like a parody of Ona with pendo of
course being a play on pendejo which
means pubic hair we also have a white
claw parody called thaw and a cheap
brand of liquor called dignity with 99
cent beer some boxes of pib waser 9
brand beer can also be seen outside
which is of course a pisswater parody of
Budweiser the door on the right side of
the frame also hilariously includes a
sign that says that Uncle Jack's no
longer takes money stored in people's
underwear as well as a sticker that says
Petty forever which appears appeared to
be a shout out to Tom Petty's 1989 song
Life is a long road that plays over the
course of this trailer also before the
doors even open during this shot we can
see a brand of soda on the right side of
the frame called Zesta which appears to
be a parody of the Fanta soda brand in
real life then when we get a shot of
them walking through the liquor store we
can see another ad for pib waser 9
hanging from the ceiling before they
walk past some Benedict liked beer
returning from GTA 5 and some type of
Coca-Cola parody with the slogan feel
the Fizz like the sheer amount of detail
on the shelves of this store alone is
insanely impressive to me like it truly
feels like a real life liquor store then
after they grab the money from the
register I think this is when we get
this shot of the two doing a big old
drift in their getaway car in front of a
gun and pawn shop before getting this
moment of Lucia and her partner being
anxious as they drive past the cops
responding to their robbery with their
very small score of a couple of $20
bills in hand like if those are truly
all $20 bills then there really can't be
more than like $300 in there in my
opinion so not really worth it if this
robbery actually happens to be what
landed Lucia in prison in the first
place the two drive past a billboard for
The Angst toan brand of anti-depressants
which are marketed as America's favorite
brand of dissociative and in order to
help sell these pills they also included
imagery of what appears to be a smiling
blue pill guy hugging a red blob forcing
a smile possibly illustrating how this
blue pill works on human emotions then
as they evade the cops Jason appears to
drive past a plaza of stores at the
Evergreen mall stores that include
Kowalski callus Scala and Alpha amongst
others but anyways moving on with the
trailer we then get this beautiful shot
of the Vice City Beach with a far more
populated Shoreline than any Grand Theft
Auto game before not only is the water
absolutely gorgeous but it's apparently
filled with wild life like dolphins as
we can see a pack of dolphins swimming
towards the direction of the shore in
the sky we can also see a plane in the
sky flying a banner for a mysterious
company called 919 that says why 69 when
you can 919 which is a good question
because I have no idea what the hell 919
even is but while we're talking about
the beach let's analyze this beach shot
that appears later on in the trailer
with the highlight of the shot of course
being the cute tiny dog running
alongside this super athletic couple
just kidding it's the ass the copious
amounts of shiny reflective ass on very
realistic looking bodies like honestly
Rockstar truly went in on the skin
detail of their characters in this game
because holy do these people
actually look like real life people
especially in the hair Department which
is a part of the human body that video
game developers have been struggling to
perfect for years due to the
complexities of hair physics however
judging by this trailer it truly feels
like Rockstar currently has the best
looking video game hair in the business
especially on all the diverse women in
this trailer which is definitely
something that should should be
applauded after years of ugly ass video
game locks in my opinion it's about damn
time we created this hair technology but
anyways we can see a good number of the
umbrellas at the beach have been
provided by a company called Soul
Sisters with S O soul referring to the
sun we can also see this dude on the
right here filming his girls booty for
all the homies on social media social
media seems to be playing a major role
in GTA 6 as the trailer presents a
number of moments within the context of
apps akin to Tik Tok and Instagram reals
like how we see an account called dadbod
Squad post this sunburnt sugar daddy
partying with a bunch of his sugar
children on a yacht or how we see an
account called official poach upload
this video of a gator being removed from
a pool we can also see a red four-door
car hauling an absolute dumb truck on
their roof posted by an account called
have a vice day before catching a live
stream of two black women dancing to a
song that a user named Zaza nugget
refers to as the best song right now so
I think there's a chance that these two
women are actually a rap Duo of some
kind akin to salt and Peppa I'm so
jealous that I did not take the Zaza
nugget username on Instagram first it's
too late now we also of course see a
video of a large man running from the
cops in front of an arrow gas station
posted by an account called Planet
leanda man with leanda being the name of
GTA's adaptation of the entire State of
Florida as Vice City is famously known
for being a virtu ual copy of Miami so
leond de man is a parody of all the
Florida Man memes and news stories on
the internet with this road raging guy
in the American flag bandana grabbing
his crotch being a prime example even
wearing a gator themed leyanda shirt and
before you guys ask I don't know if I'm
saying it right I'm just saying it
leanda because it sounds like it's like
a play on Florida so calling it leonida
like a lot of people are kind of feels
like I'm saying Florida instead of
Florida I don't know leanda sounds like
it sounds right but anyways behind this
dude you can see a billboard sprad
spreading public awareness about a panty
sniffing lunatic on the Loose as well as
Highway signage for a couple of
explorable areas in the region like the
vice beaches Vice International Airport
and Kelly County earlier in the trailer
when we get this shot of this woman who
may or may not be Lucia standing up in a
convertible we can see Highway signage
for Stockyard in downtown as well but
anyways another social media post can be
seen in the form of this dude hanging
off the side of his green pickup truck a
pickup truck with stickers on the back
for vice vinyl ride out customs and
cross town followed by footage of the
Rednecks of the thrill Billy Fight Club
having a blast in the mud and this reel
from Lucha Libre fan of a crazy old lady
from Hamlet with two hammers that is a
clear parody of a real life viral video
of a crazy Karen doing this exact same
thing with two hammers in fact a number
of shots from this trailer are actually
parodies of viral videos of people in
America doing wild ass IGN actually
posted a great compilation of all of
these moments on Twitter with the most
bizarr looking parody of them all of
course being the parody of Lauren
Sullivan AKA Florida Joker which happens
when we see this news footage from
Spanish Mega Mundo news that features
the court hearing of a man with crazy
tattoos on his face like Jared Leto's
Joker had with the Spanish text in the
lower third translating to confession
written in tattoo ink a tattoo on his
neck that gave himself away is key to
the conviction of a man from leanda
behind the tattooed man in the trailer
is a parody of the same sheriff's badge
logo that Florida Joker had during his
Hearing in real life however this badge
in the trailer has an image of what
appears to be Adam and Eve and the
serpent from the Bible in the Middle
with an Adam crouching next to an eve
standing at a Shore looking out at a
boat on the water and the snake hanging
down from a tree behind them this image
is actually a parody of the Florida flag
that has a woman amongst flowers instead
since the fall of Adam and Eve Eve is
the biblical tale of Humanity's First
Act of Vice having this Adam and Eve
imagery for Vice City related
organizations is actually kind of Genius
symbolism and to wrap up the social
media feeds we get a look at footage
from a high Roller's lifestyle car meet
with the handle high rollers mag at the
bottom left screen implying that these
people also produce a magazine for
people who like making money and Loud
vroom vroom noises with their car the
man in the middle of the shot is wearing
a t-shirt for the in Universe video game
series righteous Slaughter that we see
Michael's son playing non-stop in GTA 5
his shirt looks like it could say
righteous Slaughter blood Ops which
sounds like a parody of the Call of Duty
Black Ops franchise like I'm really
digging the vibe of the street racing
scene of Vice City and I'm really amped
to see more details about how street
racing is actually going to look online
but anyways it wouldn't be a GTA game
without a ton of vehicles and when
we get the shot of this busy street we
can see what appears to be a blue Fister
Comet S2 a white gry cheetah classic and
a red groy carbon AAR with all of these
rich ass Ballers completely ignoring
this homeless man on the street which is
very telling of how superficial and
apathetic the self-centered people of
this game actually are just going to be
one big satire on vanity much like GTA 5
was but further down the street from
these cars we can also see The Return of
the ocean view hotel from GTA Vice City
which is pretty exciting cuz I'm a big
Nostalgia freak and I like things that I
know but anyways during that earlier
Beach show out with all the people we
can also see two air vehicles in the sky
in the form of the sea Sparrow on the
right and the Buckingham super valo on
the left and when we get this shot of
this game's version of the Florida Keys
a Dodo plane can be seen flying overhead
and finally back to the night life of
Vice City we can see The Return of strip
clubs to the GTA series a staple of the
franchise itself the crowded strip club
that we see in the trailer looks like
the Jack of Hearts Club that was
revealed during the GTA 6 leaks that
dropped a little while back so this
strip club does not appear to be a
modern look at the pole position
nightclub from GTA Vice City but don't
worry if you still need your nostalgic
nut I'm sure pull position still exists
somewhere in this map but anyways that
is it for this breakdown for the first
teaser trailer for GTA 6 let us know
what you guys thought of this trailer in
the comments section below you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
or Instagram or YouTube or wherever I am
on the internet if you guys want to see
me post some weird but most
importantly follow heavy spoilers here
on YouTube YouTu so that you never miss
any uploads that we got going on cuz we
always got some really fun stuff for you
guys we're always breaking things down
and you don't want to miss it but again
thank you guys so much for watching you
guys are amazing and I'll see you guys
next time
goodbye